a new string of bomb threats against
historically black universities from
delaware to louisiana howard university
reported its second threat in two days
early this morning and multiple other
schools are reporting new bomb scares as
well jeff pagas is at howard's campus in
washington where students woke up to
this scary alert jeff good morning
yeah good morning certainly not the
wake-up call anybody would want to get
but d.c police called to this campus
early this morning at 3 a.m fortunately
no explosives found and now the all
clear on howard's campus but the list of
schools getting these bomb threats
across the country
is growing
students and staff at howard university
in washington d.c woke up to a new alert
of a bomb threat on campus for the
second day in a row the bison safe app
alerted the community just before 3 30
tuesday morning as d.c police
investigated multiple areas on the main
campus the fbi and the atf have been
busy investigating two other recent
threats at historically black colleges
and universities across the country
since early january it's very scary for
parents and students and staff as well
at bowie state university in maryland in
order to shelter and place rattled
nerves monday other schools that
received threats monday included albany
state university southern university and
a m college howard university bethune
cookman university and delaware state
university i will say that these are
certainly disturbing
and the white house is in touch with the
interagency partners including federal
law enforcement leadership on this are
they seeing a lot of threats we're just
responding to those as we speak acting
atf director marvin richardson spoke
exclusively with cbs news so literally
as we received the information we're
responding we have certified explosive
specialists who would respond to those
scenes
along with our explosive detection k-9
the congressional bipartisan hbcu caucus
is calling for a thorough criminal
investigation releasing this statement
that reads in part we will not let
terror disrupt or demean the academic
excellence of our hbc use
it's not clear if the threats received
earlier in january are related to this
latest batch of threats but obviously
it's something that investigators are
looking into tony
frightening also very disruptive there
if you're trying to learn on campus jeff
thank you very much we'll stay on it